so in the previous section
Phillips explain why the problem of
multiple pattern matching is important
and he further gave an algorithm for
solving the multiple patterns matching
problem but let's see what is the way
that he solved the problem
he is the genome as a road and he is the
pattern as a student so basically what
Phillip does is he's asked the student
to go along the road and find on the
Marches that the patent can match but
please remember that we have multiple
patterns so this approach force us to
slide the patterns along the genome
multiple times okay here we slide this
approach takes a lot of time the time
complexity of this algorithm is bigger
of the genome size multiple but by the
combined length of patterns in practice
the combined length of all the buttons
is huge and this on algorithm is not
that practical now I'm describing
another approach so instead of asking
individual patterns to go along the
genome one at a time I now pack all the
pattern into a single structure and move
the structure along the genome only once
so it is similar to packing all the
student onto a bus and move the bus just
one on the road this data structure has
a very important property it can
retrieve the patent very quickly
like if a father here ask if taka is on
this bus the bus driver can say I can
retrieve tracker target very quickly so
the this data structure is called a try
coming from the word retrieval so the
try is a data structure for representing
a collection of patterns and the tries
support fast pattern matching now given
us a set of patterns the idea is to
combine all these patterns into a rooted
tree with branches labeled by letters in
the alphabet and every string in the
patterns correspond to a path from root
to live let's go through this example
with me to understand how we can
construct a try from a collection of
patterns okay we start with the root and
the first pattern is banana so from the
root the first character of banana is B
there's no B here so we have to create a
new branch and label it might be the
next character is a so we have to create
a new branch and label it by a and so on
so forth and a so for the next pattern
PA n we start from the root there's no P
so we have to create a new range B here
okay and a and the next one is end we
start from the root there's no end going
down from the root so we have to create
one a and the next one is n D next one
is n ap net
Swiss start from the root we don't have
em so we have to create a new one and a
B okay antenna we start from the root
but please note that a
here we have a branch labeled by a so we
don't have to create a new one we just
follow it down go to next and here the
next one is T we don't have T so we have
to create a new one and E and and a the
next one is bandanna we start from the
root we have B already so we don't have
to create a new one so a and there's no
be going down so we have to create a new
one and a okay next one is Ananas we
have a already so we just follow down
and here a we don't have a we have to
create a deal a okay and a s the next
one is Nana we start from the root a
sorry Nana we go through a n a there's
no n next so we have to create a new one
here okay okay so this tree this rooted
tree is called a try constructed from
the set of patterns so a try is a rooted
tree with branches labeled by letters in
the alphabet
every patterns every button is a path
from the root to a leaf for example
banana is it correspond to a path from
the root to the leaf but please know
that in this example we have some errors
here if you want to construct a try for
yourself you need to add a new
characters dollar at the end of each
pattern we don't have space so allow us
to have some mistake here so the
question now is how to use the try for
pattern matching before Philip has to
move individual pattern one at a time
along the genome to find a match now we
have already create a
special structure called a try that pack
all the patterns into a single data
structure now the only thing we have to
do is to move this data structure along
the genome okay let's take as an example
here we have the string excel genome
Adama bananas this is they try
constructed from the set of patterns we
want too much first we put the try at
the first position of the string P and
we want to ask a question whether there
is any pattern in this connection that
can mush at this position on the genome
so we just walk down from the root here
is P so they say 1p much walk down a and
so good so at this position we can find
a much pen if we move the try to the
next position so and we try to walk down
the tree from the from the root to the
leaf of the tree to find if there is any
match so we can fight a here next one is
n next one is a yes we can find next one
is M no in the tree we don't have
anything going out from this but have
label M so at this position we cannot
find any much we move the try one more
time and and here a M we cannot find em
so that is no match at this position we
move to the next we starts with a and
here we got start we cannot match so we
have to move we can say that at this
position there is no pattern that much
this position immediately there's no
much next position a here there's no
match here we move to the next be a and
a and a s ok so we can find a match here
so we move it to the next one
a
and a and a s exactly so we can fire
much at this position so next one is n a
and a we can fire much so we move next a
and a s there's no s walking down so at
this position we cannot fly any part of
that much
similarly we move the try here we cannot
fight any much here we cannot find much
here immediately we cannot find much
okay so to recap in this section I have
described a data structure called the
try which is a representation of a
collection of strings this data
structure allows us to retrieve a
pattern from the collections very
quickly in the runtime of the try
matching now we have reduced it to the
genome multiplied by the longest pattern
where it didn't bring us algorithm that
Phillip described it text genome
multiplied by the total length of all
the patterns